the Apple silicon Mac Pro has been in
the works for years now and we finally
got a huge leak dump from Mark German
with a bunch of answers to the questions
that we had about it now the biggest
question that we're going to answer in
this video is should you actually wait
for it or should you just look elsewhere
and get a different machine right now
well let's jump right into it of course
we have Mark German's Twitter right here
and before I get into the brand new
power on newsletter that he just
released I want to go through the update
that we had last year with what's going
on with the Apple silicon Mac Pro and
unfortunately the news was that Apple
was scaling back its high-end Mac Pro
plans and canceling the M2 extreme chip
meaning that it's only going to be
running the M2 Ultra with up to 24 CPU
cores 76 GPU cores and 192 gigs of RAM
but now we just got a brand new update
with some new news in addition to the
canceling of the into extreme the
machine is going to look identical to
the current 2019 Intel model and
unfortunately there is not going to be
any user upgradable RAM and that could
be a huge disappointment to a lot of you
guys because we've been having leaks and
rumors of a smaller Mac Pro for months
maybe even years now and a lot of people
were excited for that because the
current one is huge it's massive it's
heavy it's hard to move around so a new
redesign was very exciting but now let's
actually dig deep into the power on
newsletter itself and look at all of the
details now this new Mac Pro is going to
be limited to the M2 Ultra it's not
going to have user upgradable Ram but
here's the interesting addition right
here there are still going to be two SSD
storage slots and there's going to be
GPU PCI Express slots for graphics media
and networking cards and the big
standout is the graphics that means that
either apple is going to be allowing
third-party gpus which I'm kind of iffy
about I don't think they will or they're
going to make their own custom apple
gpus and that is going to allow Apple to
increase their profit margins by just
offering that but now let's get into the
extreme chip now the leaks for the
extreme chip are kind of interesting
because way back in July of last year
mark German within an interview that I
actually conducted with him he said that
Apple actually had an M1 based extreme
Mac Pro ready to ship but they ended up
calling it off canceling it and delaying
it to wait for the second generation of
M chips and then fast forward to
December 18th when he said the M2
extreme was getting canceled that was a
huge disappointment because for me the
whole point of the Mac Pro is to be a
status symbol showing that the arm-based
chips with the M2 extreme are coming to
disrupt the entire industry and the
crazy thing is that we actually have
leaks last year like for Majin Buu
showing that Apple was legit working on
this new extreme processor with two M1
Ultras put together and you can even see
this new Ultra Fusion fabric right here
and a little diagram of the four dies
within the extreme chip so Apple was
working on it but as far as why I think
the extreme ship was canceled altogether
even for the M2 extreme it all comes
down to an exclusive source that we had
last year that told us that Apple's M1
family at chips came with a design
limitation or a flaw that ruined the GPU
scaling that didn't allow the chips to
scale that well specifically with the M1
Max where you started to see a hint of
scaling issues and the M1 Ultra that had
massive massive scaling issues now let
me show show you this this is a video
when we compared the Mac Studio three
different versions We had the 24 core M1
Max then the 48 core GPU M1 Ultra and
the fully loaded 64 core and as you can
see you're not getting perfect scaling
in terms of 3D Mark Wildlife extreme
especially going from the 48 core M1
Ultra to the 64 core it's barely faster
so we started doing calculations and you
can see here that as you get to more GPU
cores there is less FPS per core so the
scaling gets worse and now here's where
it gets into why this applies to the M2
extreme well Mark German himself and
I've been saying for a while that the M2
Chip is a stopgap chip I believe it's
basically the same design as the M1 just
tuned up and over clocked so the thing
is if the M1 Familia chips had the flaw
with scaling that's going to translate
to the M2 Chip now for a while I was
hoping that the M2 Pro and M2 Max would
come on three nanometer but it's looking
more and more like it's not going to be
three nanometer with a new design it's
looking like it's just gonna be another
improved four nanometer or five
nanometer chip and we even looked at
leaked benchmark scores for the M2 Max
chip and as you can see the single core
is pretty decent and the multi-core is
okay but it's nowhere near the score it
should be if it was actually built on
three nanometer so that means that the
entire M2 Max die and the M2 Ultra and
likely the theoretical M2 extreme would
have the same scaling issue so that's
what I believe happened I believe Apple
canceled it once they started testing
out the M2 extreme chip they saw that
the scaling was horrible they decided to
completely cancel it to not embarrass
themselves because we of course would
test it out and see this is not worth it
the scaling is bad ad don't buy the M2
extreme so unfortunately we're going to
be stuck with the M2 Ultra as the
highest end chip for the Mac Pro but
there is some good news because back in
December Mark German said that apple is
planning to move Mac Pro production
completely out of the us over to Asia
which is in Vietnam and that by itself
is gonna help Apple save money so
Apple's gonna save money on multiple
fronts they're going to save money by
reusing the same chassis they've already
been making they're going to save money
by not having to put in a GPU card and
extra Ram slots because it's all going
to be built into the M2 Max I believe
the M2 Max is going to be the base model
with an upgrade to the M2 Ultra and
they're going to manufacture it in
Vietnam so because of those reasons we
could even see four thousand or five
thousand dollars as the entry base price
for the Mac Pro but with all that said
this is going to create some issues
within Apple's High high-end Mac lineup
because we got the Max studio last year
and the interesting thing about the Mac
Studio is that it comes with the M1
Ultra as the highest end ship so if the
Mac Pro is going to have the M2 Ultra as
the highest end chip I fully believe
that apple is gonna have to do something
with the Mac Studio to make sure that
that does not get updated with the M2
Ultra because you're gonna have a choice
between the same chip either with the
Mac Studio or even more expensive Mac
Pro I don't think Apple's gonna want
that Clash so one option is to
completely discontinue the Mac Studio
altogether but I don't think that's
gonna happen I believe that apple is
going to put the Max studio on the back
burner like they're not going to care
about it for a full three years from the
release date which means we might not
even see a new Mac Studio update until
2025 when eventually I believe Apple's
gonna fix the scaling issues and it's
going to come with an M3 Ultra while we
could get a Mac Pro with finally the M3
extreme four die chip in 2025 or maybe
even 2026 I'm not sure but I believe
it's going to be put on the back burner
because we just got this report from
cirp saying that they have a new report
with the Mac model mix of the September
2022 quarter yes they were able to look
at which Macs are the most popular and
interestingly if you look right here out
of all Macs only one percent of the
sales go to the Mac Studio which is
terrible which means Apple should not
prioritize the Mac Studio at all they
can easily put it on the back burner
also only one percent for the Mac Mini
of all Max sales likely because people
are waiting for the M2 version there
were a lot of leaks but surprisingly out
of all of the desktop Max 43 of the
sales go to the Mac Pro which I didn't
think it was that high but the main
takeaway here is that the Mac Studio
doesn't sell well Apple likely doesn't
care about it they'll probably put it on
the back burner and will likely see the
M2 Ultra Mac Pro as the only way to get
that Ultra chip so that's one reason why
you would want to wait for the Mac Pro
because that's going to be likely the
only way to get an M2 Ultra chip but
then the question is how is the scaling
going to be what if the scaling is just
as bad or maybe even worse so if you
don't like the fact that it's going to
have the same chassis non-upgradable Ram
then maybe you should just forget about
the Mac Pro altogether forget about
spending all that money and literally
just go and buy a 16 inch MacBook Pro
which is about to get updated with the
M2 Max chip that's likely going to be
the best option because it is a mobile
solution but then again there are still
people buying Intel Mac Pro right now
and they have their own reasons for it
they need it for their heavy duty tasks
so if you're one of those people you
probably know already so let me know
what you think about all of these leaks
are you disappointed by the ram Thing by
the design Thing by the extreme chip
cancellation thing let me know down in
the comment section below and if you
want to see which Mac I recommend you
buy right now use the YouTube tagging
feature to see it right now so thanks
for watching click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
foreign